you guys we are heading into the finale
before we get into that
sir a cracked rib how are we feeling i
feel amazing now
i don't know what happened but after a
week of some recovery and you know just
some
laser treatment on the spot i feel
really good you're young
i think i think that that might be
effective though i think there's
something with the billboard awards and
being hurt because
i hosted a few times in two of those
times i was i had to be like rushed to a
hospital one time the next time that
something else happened
something else always happened i think i
blame the billboard awards
the curse of hosting billboards is that
there's an injury i just put this
together you got injured right before
doing that yeah
did you have a chance to watch him last
night how do you do i literally flew
one day of the weekend to dc to do
kennedy centers and then i flew to
montana to pick up my kids so i've lived
on a plane
for her i didn't see it i literally got
in at like nine last night with my kids
so
okay so she didn't get to see it but you
at least did though and they said it was
awesome
and you closed with your brothers we
closed with the brothers it was very fun
you at least
had another special woman there who was
supporting you you had your wife what
does it mean to have priyanka there
to share in all of life's moments like
that oh it's beautiful i mean
she's been shooting in the uk uh for
months now six months so she came back
for two weeks just to be at home
and i was like hey you want to present
an award uh so she did that she
presented duran duran's performance and
and she looked beautiful as always it
was great to have her there a little
date night out she glows
she's one of those women that glows do
you guys share
secrets like skincare routines share
with the class ma'am
i was like no she had not told me she
where the fountain is
where is the fountain of youth you tell
me
i love it all right we are heading into
the finale this week how are you guys
feeling heading into it
i feel like it's gone by so fast um for
me
i mean it takes forever to get to this
point because of how we shoot this
particular season
but then once it got it's only three
weeks so it feels fast
it's really fast and i've said this
before but it's my first time in the
studio for
the lives uh and you know for the finale
um so i'm just excited to see it and we
kind of just get to hang out and sit in
our chairs and just watch with the rest
of the country and occasionally throw
out some comments that happen to be
televised in front of the country um so
we can't say anything stupid
uh but yeah he's here so he handles that
part
we say the smart stuff um but it'll be
nice and and we have an incredible uh
group of finalists here they're all
really phenomenal i'm looking forward to
being entertained me too entertain us
please entertain
me i'm sure mr shelton can entertain you
guys as well with his commentary
what would what would the look on your
face be if blake wins
again i'd just be angry i would be i
would be angry that but
i am i think everyone in the finale
really is deserving so cam won i mean
way to go he's
extremely talented well yes of course
there's yeah of course you mean coach
yeah coach wise oh hell okay
i'm just kidding you know we are heading
into another season
with ariana's who's gonna join the team
ariana grande is coming
into the voice family next season nick
do you have any
words of wisdom for her uh well no i
mean she's brilliant obviously she'll
she'll nail it i've said this to someone
else you know
i think the best thing to do is just not
to trust blake
shelton uh don't just a word he says
he's a liar
and if you know that stepping into it
you'll be fine okay
kelly any what are your thoughts with
ariana grande joining my thoughts are
this is my last chance to win the voice
no i'm a huge fan of her voice i love
her voice i've only run into her a
couple times and she's so sweet like
every time we went to each other so
i'm just a fan i i would love like as a
person that's competed in a show like
this
i would love to be able to pick you know
someone like her she sings so
beautifully and is
just killing it still in the charts like
it she's just an amazing coach like to
have on the show so i think it's going
to be really cool and fun i like female
[Music]
energy